This episode is brought to you by Accenture. When your advertising operations fall out of sync, everything else follows. Spotify and Accenture are working together to reinvent the rhythm of ad sales, using automation, analytics, and smarter workflows to simplify campaign delivery and access better data across the business. The result? Less time spent on operations, more time connecting brands with the moments and fandoms that matter most. Learn more at Accenture.com slash Spotify.
本期节目由埃森哲为您赞助。当您的广告运营脱节时，其他环节也会随之出现问题。Spotify 与埃森哲正在合作重塑广告销售的节奏，通过自动化、分析和更智能的工作流程来简化投放，并获取全业务的更佳数据。结果如何？减少了花在运营上的时间，腾出更多时间将品牌与那些最重要的时刻和粉丝群体联系起来。请访问 Accenture.com/Spotify 了解详情。
Speaking of psychology is taking a summer break, so we're rerunning some of our favorite episodes from the past. In 2022, I talked to psychologist Michael Slepian about why people keep secrets, why keeping a secret bottled up inside can be harmful, and how keeping secrets and how keeping secrets and sharing them affect people's relationships with each other. I hope you enjoy this episode from the archives. We'll be back with new episodes beginning August 26th. Do you have secrets? Maybe you're looking to leave your job and don't want your co-workers or your boss to know. Maybe you still feel shame about cheating on an exam in high school. Maybe you haven't told anyone whom you voted for in the last election.
《心理学聊天室》（Speaking of Psychology）正在进行暑期休播，因此我们重播了过去一些最受喜爱的节目。在 2022 年，我与心理学家迈克尔·斯莱皮安（Michael Slepian）进行了交谈，探讨了人们为什么会保守秘密、把秘密憋在心里为什么会有害，以及保守秘密和分享秘密如何影响人们彼此之间的关系。希望您能喜欢这期来自资料库的节目。我们将在 8 月 26 日开始携全新节目回归。你有秘密吗？也许你正打算离职，不想让同事或老板知道。也许你对高中时考试作弊仍感到羞耻。也许你在上次大选中把票投给了谁，你从来没告诉过任何人。
Or perhaps a friend told you about an extramarital affair and swore you to secrecy. We keep our own secrets and sometimes we keep those of others. Research has shown that on average people have about 13 secrets at any one time, five of which they have never told another person. How does this secret keeping affect us? People often describe secrets as burdens that weigh them down or eat away at them. Do these metaphors reflect a deeper truth? Does keeping a secret bottled up inside harm us?
或者，也许某个朋友跟你讲述了一段婚外情，并让你发誓保密。我们保守着自己的秘密，有时也保守着别人的秘密。研究表明，平均而言，一个人在任何特定时间大约有 13 个秘密，其中有 5 个是从未告诉过任何人的。这种保守秘密的行为对我们有什么影响？人们经常将秘密形容为沉重的负担，压得他们喘不过气，或者蚕食着他们的内心。这些隐喻是否反映了更深层次的真相？把秘密憋在心里会对我们有害吗？
And if so, how? How does keeping secrets or sharing them affect people's relationships with each other? How do we decide whom we can trust with our secrets? And can other people tell when we're holding something back? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Michael Slepian, the Sanford C. Bernstein and Company Associate Professor
如果是的话，又是如何有害的？保守秘密或分享秘密又是如何影响人际关系的？我们该如何决定谁才是可以托付秘密的信赖对象？别人能看出我们有所隐瞒吗？欢迎收听《心理学聊天室》，这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是迈克尔·斯莱皮安博士，他是哥伦比亚大学商学院桑福德·C·伯恩斯坦公司（Sanford C. Bernstein and Company）
of Leadership and Ethics at Columbia Business School. He's a research psychologist who studies the psychology of secrets. He examines the intersection of secrecy, trust, and motivation, including the consequences. of secrecy and how we judge and develop trust. His new book, The Secret Life of Secrets, How Our Inner World Shape Well-Being Relationships and Who We Are, is being released in June by Penguin Random House. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Slepian. Thanks for having me. So let's start with the number I quoted in the introduction that people keep about 13 secrets at any one time on average and five of them they've never told anyone. Those numbers come from your research. Can you
领导力与道德规范副教授。他是一名研究秘密心理学的研究心理学家。他研究保密性、信任和动机的交叉点，包括保密带来的后果，以及我们如何判断和建立信任。他的新书《秘密的秘密生活：我们的内心世界如何塑造幸福、关系以及我是谁》（The Secret Life of Secrets, How Our Inner World Shape Well-Being Relationships and Who We Are）将于 6 月由企鹅兰登书屋（Penguin Random House）出版。非常感谢您今天能作客我们的节目，斯莱皮安博士。谢谢邀请我。那么，让我们从我在引言中引用的那个数字开始：平均而言，每个人在任何特定时间都保守着大约 13 个秘密，其中有 5 个从未告诉过任何人。这些数字来自您的研究。您能
tell us about that study? How did you arrive at those numbers? Yeah. So when we first started this research, we didn't know, we didn't have the most basic questions yet answered, like, what secrets do people keep? How often did they keep them? And so we went to find out. We asked a couple thousand people, what is the secret you're currently keeping right now? And then we looked at the responses and looked at the themes and the common instances listed. And we saw 38 categories could really well capture what those folks said that they were keeping secret. And then when we gave this list to another group of participants, sure enough, 97% of them say they have at least one of the secrets from the list right now, and the average person has 13 of the secrets from that list
给我们讲讲那项研究吗？您是如何得出这些数字的？好的。所以，当我们刚开始这项研究时，我们还不知道，最基础的问题都还没有答案，比如：人们都保守什么秘密？他们保守秘密的频率是怎样的？于是我们决定去寻找答案。我们询问了几千个人：你目前正在保守的秘密是什么？然后我们查看了回答，分析了主题和列出的常见实例。我们发现有 38 个类别能够很好地概括那些人所说他们一直在保守的秘密。接着，当我们把这份清单交给另一组参与者时，果然，其中 97% 的人表示他们目前拥有清单上的至少一个秘密，普通人在特定时间拥有该清单上的
at a given time, five of which they've never told anyone. And so these categories that we're talking about, they really comprehensively cover what people keep secret. When we ask people open-ended, what is the secret that you're keeping? Ninety-two percent of the time it fits one of these categories. So what are some of the most common secrets that people keep? Yeah, so the most common secrets include having told a lie and you don't want that to become known. Romantic desire, while you're not in a relationship, it is a very common secret. Money is another common secret, things related to sex. So how do you define a secret? Is there a difference, for instance, between a secret and something that we just consider private.
13 个秘密，其中 5 个是从未告诉过任何人的。因此，我们谈论的这些类别，确实非常全面地涵盖了人们保守的秘密。当我们以开放式问题询问人们“你保守的秘密是什么”时，92% 的情况下它都符合这些类别之一。那么，人们保守的最常见秘密有哪些呢？是的，最常见的秘密包括：撒过谎，并且不希望这个谎言败露。单身时的浪漫渴望，这是一个非常普遍的秘密。金钱是另一个常见的秘密，还有与性相关的事情。那么，您如何定义秘密？例如，秘密和我们仅仅认为是隐私的事情之间有什么区别吗？
Yeah, and in fact, there can be some gray area between, but there's a way to draw a line between the two, which is that privacy tends to sort of focus on, you know, you don't broadcast personal information very, very widely if you're a private person. And if there's something that people don't know, it may be because these aren't the kinds of things we tend to talk about. So for a lot of folks, they don't talk about money or they don't talk about sex. And so that might be why people don't know those things about you, but when it becomes a secret, it's not just that someone doesn't know this thing about you, but it's that you intend for them to not learn this information. That's when we arrive at a secret.
是的，事实上，两者之间可能存在一些灰色地带，但有一种方法可以在两者之间划清界限，那就是：隐私往往倾向于关注——如果你是一个注重隐私的人，你不会非常、非常广泛地广播个人信息。如果有些事情别人不知道，那可能是因为这些本就不是我们倾向于谈论的事情。对很多人来说，他们不谈论金钱，也不谈论性。所以这可能就是为什么别人不知道关于你的这些事情；但当它变成一个秘密时，不仅仅是别人不知道这件事，而是你打算让他们不去了解这些信息。这才是我们真正触及秘密的时候。
So let's talk for a minute about the intersection between lying and keeping a secret. For instance, I recently watched the movie Dear Evan Hanson, where Evan creates this whole complicated fiction about having been friends with a schoolmate who has killed himself. The lies that Evan tells about the relationship are they're very much like secrets. And they appear to be a heavy burden on him, much like secrets tend to be, only maybe more so because he never was friends with the other boy. So are lies just a different type of secret? So no, I would say that lying is one way you could keep a secret, but it's not the only way. There's plenty of secrets you can keep without telling lies. So a lie is one way out of many to keep a secret. And then, of course, you can keep a lie a secret. But there's sort of different constructs, but they're kind of intersecting in this way. So a lot of your work has to do with how secrets affect us often in harmful ways.
因此，我们花一分钟来聊聊谎言与保守秘密之间的交集。例如，我最近看了电影《致埃文·汉森》（Dear Evan Hanson），其中埃文编造了一个错综复杂的虚构故事，说自己曾是一个自杀同学的朋友。埃文关于这段关系的谎言非常类似于秘密。它们似乎也成了他沉重的负担，很像秘密通常具有的属性，只是可能更加沉重，因为他根本就没跟那个男孩做过朋友。那么，谎言只是另一种类型的秘密吗？不，我会说，撒谎是保守秘密的一种方法，但不是唯一的方法。你可以保守很多秘密而不用撒谎。所以，谎言是保守秘密的众多方法之一。当然，你也可以把一个谎言当成秘密保守起来。但它们在某种程度上是不同的概念，不过它们在这一点上有所交集。因此，你的很多工作都与秘密如何常常以有害的方式影响我们有关。
There's a line in an essay you wrote that said, the real problem with having secrets is not that we have to hide them, but rather that we have to live with them. So why is living with secrets so difficult? What's so difficult about just simply having a secret, a secret that you might not ever have to hide in conversation, if it's something you care about or if it's something that's bothering you, to choose to be alone with that thing tends to not help. We tend to not develop the healthiest ways of thinking about these struggles we keep entirely to ourselves. And so even whether you're hiding it frequently or not, your mind is going to return to this thing time and time again, and you're not going to know what to do with it. Are there some types of secrets that are harder to live with at others? For example, you've looked at the difference between secrets that people consider shameful and those they feel guilty about is one worse than the other. Yeah, so in one sense, if we sort of ignored what our secrets are about, we could see that the secrets that return to our minds more frequently are the ones that are also related to low well-being, not the ones that we say we can seal more frequently.
你写过的一篇文章中有一行话：“拥有秘密真正的麻烦不在于我们必须隐藏它们，而在于我们必须与它们共存。”那么，为什么与秘密共存如此困难？仅仅拥有一个秘密有什么好困难的？一个你可能永远不必在谈话中刻意隐藏的秘密，如果它是你在乎的事情，或者是一件困扰你的事情，选择独自一人面对它往往无济于事。对于我们完全独自承担的这些挣扎，我们往往无法培养出最健康的思考方式。因此，无论你是否频繁地隐藏它，你的大脑都会一次又一次地回到这件事情上，而你却不知道该拿它怎么办。有些类型的秘密是不是比其他类型的秘密更难共存？例如，你曾探讨过人们认为感到羞耻的秘密与感到内疚的秘密之间的区别，其中一个会更糟糕吗？是的，从某种意义上说，如果我们暂时忽略秘密的内容，我们会发现那些更频繁回到我们大脑中的秘密，也正是那些与低幸福感相关的秘密，而不是那些我们声称隐藏得更频繁的秘密。
But when we look to what the secrets are about, we see this distinction that you mentioned between shame and guilt. And shame, we can consider someone, when someone feels a shame, they feel like I'm a bad person to some degree. When someone feels guilty, they think I've done a bad thing. And so instead of thinking I'm a bad person, I've done a bad thing is actually much more healthy. And it's when people feel like I'm a bad person that they find their minds returning to the secret time and time again. And those are the secrets we say sort of hurt our well-being the most. And how does keeping secrets harm us? Was there research that ties secrecy directly to poor physical or mental health?
但是，当我们审视秘密的内容时，我们看到了你提到的羞耻感和内疚感之间的区别。对于羞耻感，我们可以这样看：当一个人感到羞耻时，他们在某种程度上觉得自己是个“坏人”。当一个人感到内疚时，他们会认为自己“做了一件坏事”。因此，与其认为“我是一个坏人”，不如认为“我做了一件坏事”，这实际上要健康得多。正是在人们觉得自己是个“坏人”的时候，他们会发现自己的大脑一次又一次地回到那个秘密上。而这些，就是我们所说对我们的幸福感伤害最大的秘密。那么，保守秘密是如何伤害我们的呢？有没有研究将保密性直接与不良的身体或心理健康联系起来？
So this is where things get tricky. Trying to link a specific secret to lower physical health is tough. And so, you know, there was a well-known study in the 90s that looked at men who were keeping their sexual orientation secret, who were also diagnosed with AIDS. And they found that the men who concealed their sexual orientation more often had a more rapid progression of disease and even died sooner. And so that's sort of a sobering idea. But it doesn't mean it was the part, the hiding part that was so bothering or troubling. That is when you, there's the moment in which you sort of conceal a secret during conversation, that turns out to be easier than we've made it out to be.
所以，这就是事情变得棘手的地方。试图将一个具体的秘密与较低的身体健康状况联系起来是很困难的。因此，你知道的，在 90 年代有一项著名的研究，调查了那些隐瞒自己性取向、同时也被诊断患有艾滋病的男性。他们发现，那些更频繁隐瞒自己性取向的男性，病情进展更快，甚至更早死亡。所以这算是一个令人清醒的想法。但这并不意味着正是“隐藏”这个部分带来了如此多的困扰或麻烦。也就是说，你在谈话中掩盖秘密的那个瞬间，其实比我们想象的要容易做到。
But the real problem with this situation is not feeling comfortable enough to be yourself. And that's really very reliably related to lower wellbeing. I'm feeling unsupported. And so it's having your mind return to ideas like that. I can't be who I am. I'm not supported for who I am. That seems to be where the trouble or where the harm really begins. So is there a difference between keeping our own secrets and keeping a secret for someone else,
但这种情况真正的麻烦在于：没有足够的舒适感来做真实的自己。这确实与较低的幸福感有着非常可靠的联系，也伴随着一种不被支持的感觉。因此，让你的大脑不断回到这样的想法中：“我无法做我自己”、“我真实的自我不被支持”。这似乎才是麻烦或伤害真正开始的地方。那么，保守我们自己的秘密与为别人保守秘密之间有什么区别呢？
such as one example I gave in the introduction about a friend who confesses an affair? Does keeping someone else's secrets feel as burdensome as keeping our own? It can. So if someone confides a secret in you and you have totally overlapping social networks, you're now essentially keeping the secret for them to you. Or if only certain people are allowed to know, it can get burdensome really quickly. But if it's something that's not directly relevant to some folks in your shared social network, it's not as difficult.
比如我在引言中举的一个例子：一个朋友坦白了一段婚外情？为别人保守秘密，感觉会像为自己保守秘密一样沉重吗？会的。如果有人向你吐露秘密，而你们的社交网络完全重叠，那么你基本上就是在为他们保守这个秘密。或者，如果只有特定的人被允许知道，这可能会迅速变得沉重。但如果这件事与你们共同社交网络中的某些人没有直接关系，也就没那么困难了。
When another person's secret becomes burdensome is when it becomes something we find our minds returning to time and time again. But there's a good side too. We feel glad that other people feel comfortable confiding in us. We see that as an active intimacy that brings us closer together. So sharing a secret then can bring people closer together or does it depend on the nature of the secret or even the person to whom you've told it? Yeah, so I mean, I'm imagining you're telling someone that you're already close to you. If it's someone you're not already close to you, it would be quite intimate perhaps to reveal something. that you wouldn't tell just anyone.
当另一个人的秘密变成一种负担时，是因为它成了我们发现自己的大脑一次又一次回想起的事情。但它也有好的一面。我们为别人感到舒适地向我们吐露心声而感到高兴。我们将这视为一种增进彼此亲密关系的积极行动。那么，分享秘密可以让人与人之间更加亲密吗？还是这取决于秘密的性质，甚至取决于你将秘密告诉了谁？是的，我的意思是，假设你是把秘密告诉了一个本来就很亲近的人。如果对方不是你原本就很亲近的人，向其透露一些你不会随便告诉任何人的事情，可能会显得相当私密。
But again, it's a really great way to, like, jump start a relationship. Anyone who's, you know, trying to form a relationship quickly realizes that sort of revealing sensitive things, making yourself vulnerable is a way to connect with each other. What advice do you have for people who are living with secrets that are weighing on them? How can they think about whether the risk of telling the secrets are worth the relief of being able to unburden themselves? So this is a question that is just so hard to answer on your own. And the good news is you don't have to. So you can still keep the secret from the person you're keeping it from. But you can talk to a third party and say, like, what do you think I should do with this?
但同样地，这也是快速拉近关系的一个绝佳途径。任何试图快速建立关系的人都会意识到，透露敏感的事情、让自己变得脆弱，是彼此建立联系的一种方式。对于那些带着沉重秘密生活的群体，你有什么建议？他们该如何权衡：说出秘密所带来的风险，是否值得通过卸下包袱来换取解脱？这是一个单靠自己很难回答的问题。好消息是，你不必独自面对。你依然可以向那个你原本要瞒着的人保密。但你可以与第三方交谈，并说：“你觉得我该怎么处理这件事？”
It's so helpful to just have one more perspective than your own because it's really hard to step outside of your perspective, especially when you're not sure what to do you. Talking to a third party is definitely what I would recommend in that situation. So you participated in a kind of public art project a few years ago where people could tell their secrets anonymously in a public phone installed in a park. Does that kind of anonymous sharing have the same effect? Will it make people feel better if you have a secret that you aren't ready to share with your friends or family? Is it helpful to tell it to a stranger or even write it in a diary or a journal? If you're truly not ready to tell anyone that you know or you just can't find yourself ready to talk about it,
仅仅多一个视角而不是只有你自己的视角，就会带来巨大的帮助，因为跳出你自己的视角真的很难，尤其是当你不知道该怎么做的时候。在这种情况下，找第三方谈谈绝对是我会推荐的做法。所以，几年前你参与了一个类似公共艺术项目的活动，人们可以在公园里安装的公共电话中匿名说出自己的秘密。这种匿名分享有同样的效果吗？如果你有一个还没准备好与朋友或家人分享的秘密，这样做会让人感觉好受些吗？把它告诉陌生人，甚至把它写在日记或手记里，会有帮助吗？如果你真的还没有准备好告诉任何你认识的人，或者你发现自己无论如何也无法开口谈论它，
then something like this is a good start. I wouldn't say it's everything, but it's a good start. Sometimes it just takes saying it out loud to feel like, okay, this is something I can deal with or work on. So whether you're doing that on the secret telephone, if you happen to stumble upon it in New York City or journaling. But journaling, you want to be careful because in theory it could be this great space to work through something on your own without involving. another person. But if you're using the space to simply rehash the past, it can essentially become a written record of harmful rumination. And that's when it actually harms more than it helps. And so to get journaling to work, you really want to use it as a space to step outside of your usual
那么类似这样的方式是一个好的开始。我不会说它能解决所有问题，但它是个好的开始。有时，只需大声说出来，就会觉得：“好吧，这是我可以应对或解决的事情。”所以，无论你是在那个秘密电话亭里这样做（如果你碰巧在纽约市偶然发现了它），还是写日记。但在写日记时，你需要小心，因为从理论上讲，这可能是一个非常棒的空间，让你在不涉及他人的情况下独自解决某些问题。但是，如果你只是用这个空间来不断重温过去，它基本上就会变成有害反刍的书面记录。正是在这种时候，它带来的伤害实际上大于帮助。因此，要让日记发挥作用，你真的需要把它当作一个跳出你惯常视角的空间。
perspective. The thing that's extremely hard to do on your own, really easy to do on conversation with another person. So what did you find from that phone project? What were you asking people after they told their secrets? I assume there was some kind of follow-up. this is this is what it becomes it's i wanted it to become a research project but it's so far it's an art project we haven't we haven't you know the idea was that we would program the phone so people could answer a few questions that hasn't happened yet but just we've just been looking at the things people keep secret and they're just they're quite interesting to listen to you and you know i've been doing this research for 10 years and hearing the person's voice describe the secret is
这件事情你自己做极其困难，但在与他人的对话中却非常容易做到。那么，从那个电话项目中你发现了什么？当人们说完他们的秘密后，你在问他们什么？我猜应该有某种形式的后续吧。这就是……这就是现状。我本来希望它能成为一个研究项目，但到目前为止它还是个艺术项目。我们还没有……你知道，原本的想法是我们会给电话编程，让人们可以回答几个问题，但这还没有发生。不过，我们只是在观察人们保守的秘密，倾听这些秘密相当有趣。你知道，我做这个研究已经 10 年了，听到人们用自己的声音描述秘密，
a really interesting experience i think they do something like that at burning man don't they or they have in the past. I'm sure. The phone in the desert. Yeah. So what about telling your secrets to a therapist? Is that sharing part of what makes therapy work for people? It's certainly one of the ingredients, for sure. And if that's something that you feel you'd be comfortable doing, if that might work for you, it's a great way to talk about these things without any of the risks that normally come with talking about these things to friends or family or your romantic partner even. But if that's not something you're interested in, really anyone can do this. Like anyone can sort of hear you out and say, that sucks or I'm here for you. Most folks can offer just a little bit of advice that you hadn't considered because they have this unique perspective that is not your own. So any person you would feel comfortable talking to, our research shows that the typical response to being confided in is a positive response.
真是一种非常有趣的体验。我想他们在火人节（Burning Man）上也会做类似的事情，对吧？或者过去做过。肯定的。沙漠里的那个电话。是的。那么，向治疗师吐露秘密呢？这种分享是心理治疗对人们起作用的原因之一吗？这当然是要素之一，毫无疑问。如果你觉得这样做很舒服，觉得这可能对你管用，这绝对是一个极好的方式来谈论这些事情，而没有通常与朋友、家人甚至你的浪漫伴侣谈论这些事情时所伴随的风险。但如果你对这个不感兴趣，其实任何人都可以做到这一点。比如任何人都可以倾听你的心声，并说“真糟糕”或者“我支持你”。大多数人都能提供一点你从未考虑过的建议，因为他们拥有不属于你的独特视角。因此，对于任何你觉得可以自在交谈的人，我们的研究表明，听到别人倾吐秘密时的典型反应都是积极的，
and someone has to respond very negatively for you to regret doing so. So even a lukewarm response, people find helpful. What about people whose jobs require them to keep secrets? And I don't mean proprietary information, but people who are spies, for example, or journalists who agree to protect their sources, you know, on pain of going to jail, or lawyers who might represent somebody they know is guilty, is keeping a secret because of your job the same as keeping a secret because of your job the same as keeping. being a more personal secret? They can converge. When it's something that is on your mind a lot, but you're not allowed to tell your spouse, that becomes a difficult situation, and it can feel isolating.
对方必须做出非常消极的反应，才会让你对这样做感到后悔。所以，哪怕只是不冷不热的反应，人们也会觉得有帮助。那么，那些工作要求他们必须保守秘密的人呢？我指的不是专有商业机密，而是比如间谍，或者同意以坐牢为代价保护消息来源的记者，再或者可能为他们知道已经有罪的人进行辩护的律师。因为工作原因保守秘密，与保守一个更私人的秘密是一回事吗？它们可能会交织在一起。当这是一件你经常挂在心上、却又不能告诉配偶的事情时，这就变成了一种困难的局面，并且会让人感到孤立。
We see in our research, it can feel isolating to not be able to talk about your work with other people. But there are some differences, as you might imagine to you, if the nature of the secret you keep for work is, it's not something you have to think about a lot. It seems not to be very burdensome. But if it's something big and you can't talk, about it with other folks, your mind may return to it time and time again. And then it starts looking like the harm starts looking like a personal secrets harm. Is there something in the psychological makeup of somebody who can be a spy, for example,
我们的研究表明，无法与他人谈论你的工作会让人产生孤立感。但正如你可以想象的那样，它们也有一些区别：如果你因工作而保守的秘密性质并不需要你经常去想它，它似乎就不会那么沉重。但如果这是一件大事，而你又无法与其他人谈论它，你的大脑可能会一次又一次地回到它上面。然后它带来的伤害就开始看起来像是个人秘密所带来的伤害了。比如能够成为间谍的人，他们的心理构成中是否有某种东西，
and can keep secrets and still perform every day? I mean, has anybody looked at that? I would say that someone who speaks their mind as soon as they have a thought would probably have a harder time in that job or maybe never even make it close enough to find out. Normally when we have thoughts, if there's people around, we share them. And it's not just because we want people to know what's inside our head. It's just how we connect with people.
能够保守秘密却依然能正常过好每一天？我是说，有人研究过这个吗？我会说，一个只要脑子里一有想法就要直言不讳的人，在这种工作里可能会过得很艰难，或者甚至可能根本没法接近到能被发现的地步。通常情况下，当我们有想法时，如果周围有人，我们就会分享它们。这不仅是因为我们想让别人知道我们脑子里在想什么，这也是我们与人连接的方式。
And it's also how we learn about the world. You know, you share your thought and you see what someone says in response. But if you have no trouble not sharing the thoughts that you're having, maybe you could be a spy. Can we tell when people are keeping secrets? I know there's been research into whether somebody is lying, but are there giveaways when somebody is keeping some information from you? How would you know? So in most situations, there's not any clues because people can't read your mind.
这也是我们了解世界的方式。你知道，你分享了自己的想法，然后看看别人会说什么作为回应。但如果你对于不分享脑子里的想法毫无压力，也许你就能当个间谍。我们能看出别人什么时候在保守秘密吗？我知道已经有关于某人是否在撒谎的研究，但当有人对你隐瞒某些信息时，会有什么蛛丝马迹吗？你怎么会知道呢？所以，在大多数情况下，没有任何线索，因为人们无法读懂你的心思。
They can understand if something is upsetting you or bothering you, but they can't literally see a secret on your face. And so, you know, in some ways, that's great. That's quite helpful that people can just read your secrets on your face. That would be really frustrating. And so what the studies show is that when we bring two people together in a room and have one person hide something from the other, the other person can't tell that they're hiding something often.
他们能理解有什么事情让你心烦意乱或困扰，但他们无法字面意义上地从你的脸上“看到”一个秘密。所以，从某种程度上说，这其实很棒。人们无法直接从你的脸上读出你的秘密，这相当有帮助。如果能读出来，那可就太令人沮丧了。因此，研究表明，当我们把两个人带到一个房间里，让一个人对另一个人隐瞒某事时，另一个人往往看不出他们在隐瞒什么。
And people who watch the video recordings can't tell that they're hiding something. And so why is that the case? Intuitively, we'd think that maybe we would, people would somehow tell. People would somehow be able to tell. And I think when we think about that picture in our mind, we're sort of imagining the most difficult secrecy situation we can imagine. Someone asks you a question directly related to your secret. It turns out in real life, that doesn't happen very often.
观看录像的人也看不出他们在隐瞒什么。那么，为什么会这样呢？直觉上，我们可能会认为也许我们会……人们会以某种方式看出来。人们在某种程度上会能够看出来。我想，当我们脑海中浮现出那个画面时，我们想象的是我们能想象到的最困难的保密情况：有人直接问了一个与你的秘密相关的问题。事实证明，在现实生活中，这种情况并不经常发生。
People don't go around asking people so much, have you ever cheated on your partner? Were you ever abused during childhood? These are just not questions we ask. You know, these aren't topics that necessarily come up in conversation so much, experiences of trauma. And so those kinds of secrets, it's really hard to imagine how someone could somehow know that you're keeping them. Now, if it's your romantic partner, however, here's where things become different. If there's a conversation topic that you're avoiding, which is one way, one frequent way folks trying to keep secrets from their romantic partners, your partner's going to be able to tell. If there's just a conversation topic you'd ever seem to touch or sort of dodge whenever it comes up, they're going to notice that.
人们不会到处去问别人诸如“你有没有背叛过伴侣？”“你童年时有没有受过虐待？”之类的问题。这些根本就不是我们常问的问题。你知道，这些并不是谈话中必然会出现的话题，比如创伤经历。因此，对于那种秘密，真的很难想象别人怎么可能会知道你在保守它们。然而，如果是你的浪漫伴侣，情况就不同了。如果你在回避某个谈话话题——这是人们试图对浪漫伴侣隐瞒秘密的一种常见方式——你的伴侣就会看出来。如果某个谈话话题你从不提及，或者每当它出现时你总是闪烁其词，他们就会注意到这一点。
And that is not going to be good, as you might imagine, when we believe our partners are keeping secrets from us, one of the reasons that's so hurtful is we feel not included in their lives. So you start your new book with a personal story about how you learned a significant family secret that your parents had kept from you until well into your adulthood when you were already doing research on the psychology of secrets. Can you tell that story and how has that affected the work that you're doing now? Yeah. So when I first started researching secrecy, I was doing it in a sort of strange way because I wasn't trying to learn about secrecy. I was trying to learn about metaphor, which you mentioned earlier. And secrecy was just one example, this idea that people describe secrets as heavy or weighty or burdensome. I was sort of interested in what secrets people associate with a sense of burden.
正如你所能想象的那样，这可不是什么好事。当我们相信伴侣对我们有所隐瞒时，这种感觉如此痛苦的原因之一，就是我们觉得被排挤在他们的生活之外了。所以，你的新书以一个个人故事开头，讲述了你是如何得知一个重大的家庭秘密的——你的父母一直对你保密，直到你成年很久、甚至你自己已经在研究秘密心理学的时候。你能讲讲这个故事吗？这又是如何影响你现在正在做的工作的？是的。所以，当我最初开始研究保密性时，我其实是以一种有点奇怪的方式进行的，因为我当时并不是为了了解保密性。我是为了了解隐喻，也就是你之前提到过的。而秘密只是其中一个例子，即人们将秘密描述为沉重、有分量或负担重的这种观念。我对人们将哪些秘密与负重感联系在一起很感兴趣。
And so I had been doing that research for a couple of years. And in fact, there was one particular day when I was giving my job talk to Columbia. So I'm on my interview at Columbia for my position. And I feel like it goes well. I present my research on secrecy to them. And then later that night, when I'm actually still with people from the interview, getting drinks at a bar, I got a call for my dad. And, you know, he never calls so late at night.
所以，我做这个研究已经有好几年了。事实上，正是在其中某一天，我在哥伦比亚大学做工作汇报。当时我在哥伦比亚大学面试我的职位。我觉得进展很顺利。我向他们展示了我对秘密的研究。然后到了那天晚些时候，当我实际上还和面试官们在一起、在酒吧喝一杯时，我接到了我爸爸打来的电话。而且，你知道的，他从来不会这么晚打电话。
And so I became really concerned. Something bad has happened. And you call it again. And I'm like, oh, no. You know, maybe there's been a death in the family or something. And so I finally get in touch with him after the interview was officially over, said goodbye to everyone. And he says, Michael, I need to tell you something.
因此我开始非常担心。一定是发生了什么坏事。然后你又回拨过去。我想，天哪。你知道，也许家里有人去世了之类的。所以，在面试正式结束、向每个人道别后，我终于联系上了他。他说：“迈克尔，我需要告诉你一件事。”
are you sitting down? And then he goes on to tell me, I didn't sit down, he goes on to tell me that he's not biologically able to have children. He is telling me that he's not my biological father. And this is after a day of presenting my research on secrecy as part of this interview. And as you can imagine, that's very shocking to learn about. But much later, I realized essentially at the same time that my research was coming to this conclusion that it's not the act of hiding and conversation that's very difficult, but it's
“你坐下了吗？”然后他接着告诉我……我没有坐下，他接着告诉我，他从生物学上讲是没有生育能力的。他在告诉我，他不是我的亲生父亲。而这正发生在我作为这次面试的一部分、展示我对秘密的研究的一天之后。正如你所能想象的那样，得知这一点非常令人震惊。但很久以后，我意识到，几乎是在我的研究得出结论的同一时间——即在谈话中隐藏的行为其实并不难，而是
having to think about a secret and live with it alone in your thoughts. And I realized my parents' situation was really a perfect illustration of that because I had asked my parents much later, when did you decide to keep this secret? I assumed it was either after I was born, shortly after I was born, or shortly after my younger brother was born. And my mom said neither. We had decided that we would never tell our children and we could tell anyone else, but we would never tell our children. And they decided that before we were ever born. And this is why secrecy, we really need to define it as an intention because the moment you intend to keep the secret, you have it. And they were keeping that they had this secret well before
你必须思考一个秘密并独自在思想中与它共存——我意识到我父母的情况确实是一个完美的印证。因为我后来问过我父母：“你们是什么时候决定保守这个秘密的？”我以为要么是在我出生后不久，要么是在我弟弟出生后不久。我妈妈说都不是。我们决定永远不告诉我们的孩子，我们可以告诉别人，但绝对不告诉我们的孩子。他们在我们出生之前就做出了这个决定。这就是为什么对于秘密，我们真的需要把它定义为一种意图，因为当你打算保守秘密的那一刻起，你就已经拥有它了。而且他们早在甚至还无法隐藏它之前，
they could even hide it. They could, it could already cast doubts and worries. What if we looked different from my father or what they needed to know about our genetics? And so they told me that a lot of what was difficult about having that secret was not that they once a while had a hide it in conversation that in fact was very rare, but they just had this once and a while think about it and certain things would bring it back to the top of their minds. And that is where the burden would come from. And what precipitated your father's telling you when he told you? And did he know that this was an important day for you and that you would just finish an interview
就已经在保守这个秘密了。它本可以已经投下怀疑和担忧：如果我们长得跟父亲不一样怎么办？或者他们需要了解我们的遗传学知识吗？所以他们告诉我，拥有这个秘密之所以艰难，很大程度上并不是因为他们偶尔需要在谈话中隐藏它（事实上这非常罕见），而是他们偶尔必须去想它，某些事情会把这件事重新推回他们脑海的最顶端。这就是负担的来源。是什么促使你父亲在那个时候告诉你这些？他知道这对于你来说是个重要的日子吗？你当时刚刚结束了一场工作面试？是的。所以，我了解到他们非常刻意地等到面试结束。
for a job? Yes. So I learned that they very considerably waited for the interview to be. you over. They wanted to tell me that day, though, because maybe the day or two days before, my brother had found out about the secret. And the way he found out about it was he was on a phone, on a phone call with my mom. They were chatting. She mentioned offhandedly that she recently got in an argument with her father, our grandfather. My brother was like, that's so weird. I've never heard of you two arguing ever. What were you arguing about? And she said, I can't tell you. It's a secret.
不过他们那天确实想告诉我，因为可能在前一天或两天前，我弟弟发现了这个秘密。他发现的方式是：他当时正和我妈妈通电话。他们在聊天。她漫不经心地提到她最近和她的父亲（我们的外公）吵了一架。我弟弟就觉得：“这太奇怪了。我从来没听你们俩吵过架。你们在吵什么？”她说：“我不能告诉你。这是个秘密。”
And he was like, well, now you have to tell me. And she was like, no, I promised I would never tell you. As soon as you can imagine, that's a great way to get someone to keep pushing and pushing until they, until they learned the secret. And he did. And once he learned it, they had to let me know. But they wanted to wait until the interview was over before they told me. Wow.
然后我弟弟就说：“好吧，现在你非得告诉我不可了。”而她说：“不，我答应过我永远不会告诉你。”正如你所能想象的那样，这是促使某人不断追问、直到他们得知秘密的绝佳方式。他确实这么做了。一旦他知道了，他们就必须让我知道了。但他们想等到面试结束后再告诉我。哇。
So what next? What do we need to know about secrets? What are you looking into going forward? So in thinking about what it means to have a secret. and what you should do with it. One thing that we've sort of alluded to already is talk to a third party because they have a unique perspective that they can offer you. That's really hard to find on your own.
那么接下来呢？我们需要了解关于秘密的哪些事情？你接下来在研究什么？因此，在思考拥有秘密意味着什么以及你应该对它做些什么时。我们已经暗中提到过的一点是：去找第三方谈谈，因为他们可以为你提供一个独特的视角。这是你靠自己很难找到的。
And that's part of the problem when you're living alone with a secret. You're sort of stuck with your one way of thinking about it. What we're doing now is starting to consider what the secrets are about. And when I say there's 30 categories of secrets, that's too many categories for understanding which secrets hurt you more than others. And so what we're doing now is understanding how people perceive their secrets as sort of compared to each other. And it turns out that people see their secrets as having three primary dimensions, whether it's a secret to moral, whether a secrets related to our relationships and whether a secrets related to our goals. And they're trying to understand the unique qualities of those three different dimensions or experiences we can have with our secrets.
这也是当你独自与秘密共存时遇到的问题的一部分。你有点被困在自己看待它的那一种方式里了。我们现在正在做的是开始研究秘密到底关乎什么。当我说有 30 个类别的秘密时，要搞清楚哪些秘密比其他秘密更具伤害性，这个分类实在太多了。因此，我们现在正在做的是去了解人们是如何将他们的秘密彼此进行对比的。结果证明，人们认为自己的秘密具有三个主要维度：秘密是否关乎道德，秘密是否关乎我们的人际关系，以及秘密是否关乎我们的目标。并且我们正试图理解这三个不同维度的独特品质，或者说我们与秘密的种种经历。
Well, thank you for joining me today, Dr. Sleppian. really interesting and I promise I won't tell anyone what we talked about. Thanks for having me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www.combeckoningophyscology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org.
好的，非常感谢您今天能来做客，斯莱皮安博士。这真的非常有趣，我保证我不会把我们谈论的内容告诉任何人。谢谢你邀请我。您可以在我们的 www.combeckoningophyscology.org 网站上找到往期的《心理学聊天室》节目，也可以在 Apple、Stitcher 或您获取播客的任何平台上收听。如果您喜欢我们的节目，请给我们留下评价。如果您对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，可以通过 speaking of psychology at APA.org 给我们发邮件。
Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman, our sound editor. is Chris Kondayan. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《心理学聊天室》由利·威纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作，我们的音频编辑是克里斯·孔达扬（Chris Kondayan）。感谢您的收听。我是来自美国心理学协会的金·米尔斯。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。